Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday,
December 31st,
2018 case.
You thought there was 32 days in December.
This is the last day of 2018.
What are you going to do with it?
Are you going to theses the day?
Seize the day,
Aka cram too much shit into a 24 hour
periods so you're fucking stressed out for
the next day. That's how I do it.
That's how I do it. Oh, by the way,
guess what? I finally got that little
fucking piece I needed for my, uh,
for my headphones and it works
great. And uh, as you see,
I sat there and I fucking
pitched about it for what?
Six fucking felt like nine years.
Yeah.
I just ordered it on Amazon.
It showed up, you know,
some fucking eight year old put on
a welding mass. He made it there.
Then somebody else fluid on a fucking,
yeah.
What do you call those goddamn things
that hover over your neighborhood? Drone.
Yeah.
Yeah. I Dunno. Anyways,
happy new year to you.
Happy New Year to you.
You're going to get shit faced.
Call an Uber or a Lyft.
Um, I'm actually going to be going out
tonight for the first time in a long time.
We're going to be going up, going
out with my, uh, my whole family,
my family back east. We're just
going to go out to dinner. Uh,
it's cool being a dad, you
know what I mean? Right.
Then I'll go on and go
booze and all that shit.
He just fucking call two days before.
Do you have a reservation
at four in the afternoon?
Four 30 the leg. Why? Yes. Yes we do.
It's like any other day here at four
or four 30 in the afternoon. However,
you know, started at
around seven. No, we don't.
I'm completely booked and everything's
going to be jacked up the a hole. So, uh,
we're all gonna go out and have a,
hopefully a pleasurable meal,
enjoyable dinner and
all that type of stuff.
And then I go to the rose bowl the next
day and then the following day gave me a
ticket on an aero plane.
Okay.
Gonna go fly to fucking eastern Europe.
I'm going to go to Cologne,
Germany,
and then I'd start and I am ready baby.
I put it at the time I
did the fucking work.
I was down in the comedy
store every night,
the last three nights and the ice house.
You know, I fucked up a Thursday night.
I fucking, I fucked up twice on my
gigs this week, which I never do.
I actually was headlining the
ice house and I'd forgotten.
I put in at the comedy store,
some pulling into the comedy store at
like nine o'clock and I just happened to
look down at my phone and I see a Joe
Rogan phone call and he was the one who
told me to, you know, that they
wanted to book me at the Ice House.
Then I was like, oh fuck. And then I saw,
I had a bunch of messages from the club
owner and they called up. I was like,
what time was I supposed to be on stage?
He's like right now, 10 minutes ago.
So I drove out there like a maniac.
I finally learned how to use
the supercharger in my car.
Okay.
You know, so I was in a intense
mode. Whatever the fuck they call it.
Like I drove that car
for fucking two years.
Never using the supercharger cause I
didn't know you had to push a button.
I just start when I stepped on the gas,
like the old days,
it would just engage over
there but it didn't. So uh,
I finally learned how to
use that thing and um,
what is going on with these fucking wires?
Why can't I get him ever? Not, we just,
I'd have someone understand how this
fucking happens every single time.
Every week,
every week. You know, it's weird.
You could take a handful of wires and
throw them on the ground and then once you
pick one of them up, they
all tied together. You know,
it's so weird that you can
do that with like wires,
but you can't do it with snakes.
If you throw them on the fucking ground
and you just picked one of 'em up,
they wouldn't be a bunch of
them all tangled up in it.
They all just fucking slither away.
Okay.
That's what I'm saying is we need to
start making wires the way the good lord
makes the snakes. Um, anyways,
so then I had to drive all the
way back to the comedy store.
Okay.
Because I was so fucking
late at the ice house.
I hung out and took pictures
and sign shit. Do you know
what to make up for that?
Did the full hour. Then I went all the
way back to the fucking comedy store.
I got there, but like a quarter to
12 at night and I got to tell you,
and I even gone up,
you know,
I never went up really late at the comedy
store because I never got past there
to go through that. And I
went back to me, you know,
I audition for Mitzi and she said I ain't,
she didn't say anything.
She left in the middle of my second.
That's how fucking awful she thought
I was. And she's probably right.
Um, if I'm going to be mature
about it. And then I just,
I moved back to New York and I sorta did
the late night thing in New York and I
never got to do at the comedy store and
that's probably the latest I've gone on
there since I can remember. And it was
just a completely different animal.
I went on in the main room and,
and then also when the original room and
in the main room I was on stage and I
was thinking about Richard Pryor for
some reason because I know that there's
some older guys there told me how he used
to work out his stuff late night there.
And then when I went into
the, or I was, you know,
I just went up there and I had like this
fucking set where it was just totally
free refund set, all his shit. Didn't
take any of it, just shit that I would,
a few things, I remembered
that now in my act, but like,
and I remember hearing this story that
Jim Carrey came up with fire Marshall
Bill late night in the or at the
comedy store and all that Shit.
So it was really ended
up being really cool.
And then I worked two shows Friday there
to show Saturday and then last night I
was running my hour in the main room and
then I was running over to the whiskey
because Steven Adler was playing.
And um,
I also had another spot in the AOR,
but instead of just doing an hour,
I did like an hour and 40 in the main
room and I was going to be late for the
Steven Adler show. So I was like, is
it cool if I just don't do that spot?
Because I didn't know that they
advertise me in that room too.
I thought they just advertise
me in the main room,
but they had also advertise me in the EOR.
Had I known that I would've
gone over there and done it.
I just thought I had a spot and I,
and I missed it because I was supposed
to go off at 10 15 and by the time I got
off stage in the main room,
it was like 10 40. I was like,
I don't want to fuck it up over
there, you know, for the other people.
So anyways,
long story short,
I saw Steven Adler fucking great show
at the whiskey and then I'm walking back
to the store and I'm walking in front
of the store and these four people are
standing there like fucking two of them,
one 30 in the morning going like,
you've gotta be shitting me,
you're going to go on now. I go,
we talking about it was on in the main
rooms, it could know you were in the Olr.
We were sitting there for five hours.
The whole crowd was fucking pissed off.
So I, I dunno, I got to try to figure
out how to fucking make that right.
But I felt like a fucking asshole.
So I took a picture with them and um,
I dunno. I Dunno. I was thinking,
why the fuck did I do that?
Cause then went over to the Adler
thing and it started like, you know,
20 minutes later I would have had
time to do it then I wouldn't have
disappointed those people and now
I feel like a fucking asshole.
Um, but I haven't said
that, you know, I, I,
I basically did like
seven sets in missed one.
So what are you going to do? Uh, but
dude, the fucking Adler appetite show,
that thing was fucking great man. And I
was just sitting there, the whole show.
I was just watching Steven
because I started listening,
you know?
Yeah,
I dunno.
I,
I kinda tuned up my drums and I got some
different heads and shit and they sound
fucking killer and a then my drum teacher
came over and he fined tuned it and
now it just sounds fucking unbelievable.
And uh,
I was listening to just that appetite
album again and I'm such a drum nerd.
Do you realize that Steven Adler
does not hit his rack Tom until like,
like the fourth song,
like halfway through the fourth song,
he crushes that album
just with a bass drum,
snare and his floor. Tom, the only
time we really hits the floor, Tom,
is the breakdown during
a welcome to the jungle
out to get me as all just kick snare.
Uh,
no, I'm sorry. Uh, what's the next
I would say to get me, it's uh,
it's so easy is our kick snare
and what's the next one?
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh,
data that's on the other side. I
don't fucking know. But anyway,
so I was watching him and then
when I watched him last night,
the fill that I thought he was doing and
one of those fucking songs a actually
didn't do on the rack, he actually
went from the snare over to the floor.
So I actually think he goes
maybe to, uh, Mr. Brown stone.
Nobody even then that's a for Tom.
But I remember seeing this whole fucking
thing she does is born a lot of you
guys. But uh, I remember seeing this
whole fucking thing on that for awhile.
He only had a three piece and it's just
amazing how he's so style came out of
being a broke musician and just
crashing at people's places.
He couldn't have a big
drum kit if he wanted to.
He started out for the Double Bass Kit.
I remember reading in
his book and then um,
they got rid of that.
You got rid of that somehow?
Somebody said don't play the double
bass just played a single bass drum
assumption that long. It,
it's like a Barnum thing.
And then he was down to like just a floor.
Yeah,
kick and snare and just the, the amount
of music that that guy got out of it.
But uh,
yeah,
it was awesome.
It was just do what a bunch of
characters at the whiskey last night.
Jesus Christ, there was this fucking
guy there, right. And I just,
he, he looked and he looked like he was
like in his fifties but he looked like he
had a hard life.
So he was probably like in his
forties and he's just standing.
All of a sudden the bouncer comes up and
he just hit some like slaps him on the
arm, like what the fuck? And then the
guy kind of just is like, hey man,
you know what I mean? It's
cool, whatever. And the bounce,
it just grabs them if fucking throws him
out of the club is my buddy I was with
went up and said, hey man, just started
curiosity. What did that guy do?
And I guess the guy had
taken out his lighter
and was fucking lighten the ass of the
person in front of him like some other
dude. So when the bouts hit, I'm
like, what the fuck are you doing?
When he was making this gesture like yeah,
it's kind of funny right in the punches.
Just get the fuck outta here.
You fucking lighten people on 40. What
are you giving somebody have a hot foot,
50 years of fucking age.
And my other buddy was with was
laughing his ass off because so loud.
I mean I could have just gone to him,
but he was sitting there going
like was laughing going, yeah,
I saw the whole fucking thing.
Like you didn't even try to hide it.
It's a complete fucking asshole.
Um,
so anyways, uh, that's why I did it.
My apologies to the people that
came down to the, or last night.
I feel I really feel fucking
badly about that, man. I, I,
I mean there's a hand, I don't know how
many times in my life I've missed a spot.
I would, I would think it's under
10 my entire fucking career. Um,
the first nine times nobody gave a fuck.
Um,
so my apologies. I hope that somehow I
can make that up to you guys. Um, anyways,
plowing ahead here. Uh, speaking of shows,
we've added two more amazing comics. These
guys are kids to me, but they're not,
they're fucking dead. They're like
legit. I'm just old as shit. Joe List.
And Mark Norman had been added to the
lineup for the seventh annual Patrice
O'Neal comedy benefit. I had the privilege
of working with both of them. Uh,
Mark Norman.
I worked at the West Side Comedy Club
in New York City and Joe Lists, uh,
when I did Gotham, uh, about a month
ago, I got to work with both of them and,
uh, just, just fucking like
there they are like the next,
um, just legit, legit,
straight up fucking comedians
and we'll be monster headliners.
So come down and see them now.
While you still can.
Um, also on the show is, I've
been mentioning Michelle Wolf,
Chris Read Jim Gaffigan,
uh, Gary Gulman, Rich Vos,
sec the sounds big. Jay
Oakerson and myself. It's going
to be a monster, monster,
monster show and thanks to
the Joe Rogan experience. Uh,
we had 800 tickets to sell and
now we're down to like 150. Um,
so people can buy tickets@www.new
York city. Oh, sorry.
And why city center.org or on my website,
which is [inaudible] dot com if you
just click on the events or whatever the
hell it is, road gigs or some shit like
that. If you just click on that shit,
you'll see, uh, the link
right there. Um, all right,
so they go speak in a rogue. And you know,
I mentioned when I did his podcast how,
uh, I took a sauna with them afterwards
and he has like a legit sauna, you know,
the ones would like to Kohl's and
shit that you dumped the water on.
So I felt so great after that.
That was kind of Jones and
for another one. So I went
to this fucking place, Audi,
I'm not going to say the name cause I'm
Kinda gonna like not shit on the place,
but it's just more like I,
it was a different kind of
different kinds of sauna,
um,
where Joe's is the old school one that uh,
that like, you know, the heat hits you
from the outside and you sweat like that.
I went to one of those infrared ones,
the clear light fucking ones,
which I realize is this whole debate on
whether or not those things are healthy
or not. And they say, yeah, you know,
we checked out the fucking
raise on this thing, it's fine.
And then you're supposed to ask them,
well, how did you measure those rays?
Is there any radiation?
Because they were like this thing,
like he eats you from the inside
is the way they described.
And I go, really? I go,
I feel like I'm getting into a
microwave and I got to tell you,
I stayed in there for a fucking hour
and when I came out I definitely felt
better. But afterwards I didn't feel
right. It just didn't feel right.
It wasn't that same peaceful feeling
that I had coming out of the other ones.
So, uh, I didn't like the infrared ones,
although I heard that some Hollywood
starlets that just whereby him,
I guess they use it for weight loss.
And I will tell you, I came out to them.
My stomach was definitely flattered,
but I have these, I'm like,
isn't that all water weight?
You know, he'd go out and
have one SAS Barilla there.
Your fucking belly comes right back.
Isn't, isn't that how it works? Um,
but anyways, some, uh, going to
go do this, this Europe tour,
and I'm hoping to hit a couple of
those places when I'm over there. Um,
this is going to be an unprecedented
road trip for me in that I won't be
drinking.
I don't even know that I'm going to smoke
cigars because I had like fucking 90
over the past week, you know,
catching up with end of the year. Hey,
let's get a fucking to go.
Um,
so I won't be smoking cigars.
I got vitamins with me.
I'm going to try to be hitting Saunas
and fucking getting eight hours sleep.
Uh, just cause it my fucking age, man.
I can't be doing like city to
city to city to city, 10 days,
two shows almost every fucking night, you
know? Oh my God, I was going to say this,
but by the end of the tour I'm
going to have a fucking cane.
I saw a guy last night,
it was people that have fucking
chains and it's just like, dude,
you don't need a fucking chain.
This guy was like walking with his
cane and he would take like three steps
before you put the cane down. You know,
it was like watching a point guard,
dribbling the ball up the court. Were
you just watching the whole time going?
Like the guy's fucking traveling.
If you ever sat on an NBA game,
like you fucking watch these guys,
the bouncing the ball like so fucking
high and he watched him. One, two,
three bounce. One, two, three
bounce. One, two, three pounds.
One to bounce, one, two,
three. It's just like,
and she's supposed to,
I mean that wasn't really a step and
a half. I Dunno how it fucking works.
I'm done. I'm done pitching about
sports and the way it is nowadays.
I've finally given into the fact that his,
his change and speaking of which
my patriots beat the New York jets,
who I was impressed
with their quarterback.
I don't know if he's going to be the
Guy Buddy. Uh, you know, you never know.
It might be coaching, might
be his line. I have no idea.
But he made some good frozen,
there was a lot of fucking heavy
hits by their defense. You know,
they have an another rough
year or whatever, but um,
we handled them.
We got a playoff spot.
We got to buy for the nighttime
nine years in a row we got to buy.
But that fucking mother fucking
stupid ass fucking Dolphin's game now.
Now we're going to have
to go through Casey.
If we win our game and
they win their game. Wait,
we're gonna have to go
through Kansas City.
We have to try to beat those fucking
guys again in their own goddamn building.
And, um, I dunno, I don't, I don't,
I just don't see that happening with the,
I dunno,
which weird this year we have actually
have a really good running game it seems.
Um,
but it's hard to gauge because we were
playing the jets and they were all banged
up on defense. So I don't, I don't really
know where the fuck we stand here, but,
um, but who knows. Kansas City,
you know, they also have to win,
which is not something that they've done
in the post season for a long fucking
time. But, uh, that my home's guys on a
whole other level and I don't know that,
you know,
Paul Versey made up a great fucking point.
I'm just saying that, you know, I don't,
I think this is the first time Andy
Reid has ever had a quarterback.
I know we had done of and
McNabb and all that shit.
But I really think this smart homes guy,
he has that,
he seems to have that you almost have
to be like not human at the end of the
game where you just don't feel emotion.
You know,
Bruce, he basically said,
all right, I don't like,
cause I liked him that if he goes, this
is the first time, you know, he had,
he has got a guy like bombs.
He didn't have a guy, you know.
Yeah.
You know, he was in Philadelphia and had
a guy who puked in the fucking huddle or
whatever. Um, which I don't
know, that's probably overblown.
Oh, who knows. He probably went
to a party the night before,
I'm sure fucking Ken Stabler puked
in a couple of fucking huddles.
Um, anyways, and uh,
congratulations to the Cleveland
browns and just a great season. And uh,
I was really pulling for you guys
yesterday just to see you have a winning
season and all that shit. Um, I dunno,
we'll say this is going
to be a great post season.
Of course I'm gonna be overseas and miss
some of it and if my patriots aren't
going to win at all,
I almost want us to lose in the first
round just so I can sit there and fucking
enjoy it. I know I'm going to enjoy, uh,
the NFC,
um,
playoffs just as far as like, you
know, the saints have home field.
I still don't think drew Brees has ever
gotten the fuck him respect he deserves,
he's one of those guys where he's going
to have to win two to people for people
to be oh yeah. But then
again, Elis one, two,
when they're treating him
like a fucking stepchild. Um,
I dunno when the rams were just killing
it the whole season and then they kind
of had that little dip there
and now they're kind of back.
But they also played the 40
niners so I dunno. I Dunno.
And then you got Seattle and they got
Pete Carroll's a great fucking coach.
Anything can happen and then
Chicago has that great tea.
This is going to be fucking fun.
It's going to be fun.
I always always kind of wondered too,
like what Brady must feel like being
this far into his goddamn career where he
must feel like a,
a fucking a townie at the bar and
everybody else has kind of gotten on with
their lives.
Just looking around the locker room,
like where the fuck is
everybody that I used to know?
They're all fucking gone and in like
there's no quarterback left in the league
that was playing when he started
out. I mean, I almost think like,
I mean he makes fucking Eli and
drew Brees look like youngsters.
Um,
kind of the way the rolling stones kept
Aerosmith young for so long where they
were able to kind of breeze through their
forties, 50s and into their sixties,
because the stones were always
10 years older than them.
So everyone was always making the
old jokes with, with them. So, um,
I dunno, and for all you fucking,
uh, Europe counts over there.
I did watch Liverpool arsenal,
I watched until it was three to
one and then daddy duty took over.
Bo Arsenal goes up one to nothing
and I'm thinking, okay, you know,
that fucking guy does his little dancey
slides on his knees. And I'm like, Oh,
here we go.
Arsenal.
I arsenals actually a team that
I've fucking heard they must be,
they must be one of the good fucking
teams. And then, uh, the Liverpool guys,
they just went right
down the fucking field.
Like fucking three minutes later,
Bam, 90 seconds later, Bam,
which you never see in fucking soccer,
football, whatever the hell you call it.
It's the same guy who are, you guys hadn't
scored at all in the premier league?
MMM.
Just weak ass fucking defense.
The one we're most salad kind of fucking
weaved his way through and then made
that sick pass to put the
third goal or something.
When they showed the diff defense
in slow motion, it looks lit.
Literally looked like they were extras
in a movie and mall was like the star
that they had to make look good. So they
would do in these halfhearted sort of,
I don't know what, trying to get
their foot in the way. It's like,
don't they usually just fucking stick a
clean right in the back of your fucking
Achilles? I Dunno. I don't know shit
about these Goddamn that God damn sport,
but I have been watching
or whatever. Um, all right.
Let me read a little bit
of advertising here. Um,
what do we got here? This is,
I'll simply safe everybody.
Don't you want to be simply safe in 2019?
Isn't that where you want to be?
Simply safe? Uh, we all put off doing
things we, we know we need to do.
I mean, we know we need to
do organize the garage or,
yeah,
please personalize your own ideas.
Yeah.
They literally trying to write this.
In my, my fucking, the way I speak,
this is all written like this. We all
put off things we know we need to do.
I mean,
we know we need to organize the garage.
Okay.
But something always gets in the way.
Funny how home security can be like that,
you know? Well, what I
need to organize, um,
I dunno,
I cleaned up my fucking drum room,
change the head on all my drums,
so you know what I actually do.
Yeah.
Moved all the drums out of there and I
brought a little vacuum cleaner and they
were, and I, all the fucking,
all the fucking shavings and shit and
broken drum sticks and all that from the,
uh, from the drum sticks, vacuumed
all of that shit up. And, um,
yeah. I don't know what
this has to do with safes,
but that was definitely a personal story.
Funny how some security can be like
that. You know, it's a good idea,
but there's always something
holding you back. Well,
now it's time to act because
simply safe home security,
extended holiday sale ends soon.
Simply safe believes nothing should come
between you and protecting your home.
So they've gotten rid of the
reasons not to get home security.
There's no contract,
no price markups from any middleman
and no installation windows.
Who has time for that? Who has
time for that? Most of them. Well,
you're not going to do it.
You can hire somebody to do it.
I guess most importantly,
their system is engineered to do
one thing brilliantly protect.
So if a storm takes out power,
simply safe is ready.
If an intruder cuts your phone line,
If they destroy your keypad or a siren,
simply safe.
We'll get you the help you need.
Maybe it's overkill.
Maybe it's the last thing you
want to think about this holiday.
But with simply safe,
you're always ready for anything.
Just go to simply safe.com/burr and
order January before January 8th to save
with their extended holiday sale.
That's simply safe.com/bar hi,
simply safe.com/bar all right.
Simply spelled s, I. M p. L. I.
S. A. F. E has the eye instead of the why.
You know like the way a hot chick
spells her name, you know what I mean?
They always have like the I instead
of a y. You ever notice that?
Like have a chick has
the wire in their name.
Then they're just fucking regular looking
like you and you're not intimidated to
approach them and fucking
hit on him or whatever.
If you're still allowed to do that,
you know,
are you still allowed to do that?
You don't have to. One of my shows,
this woman came up to me, she's like,
ah, I just want to give you a hug,
and I just put my hand straight up in the
air and the whole town was like, ah, me,
Toby toe. Oh, I got
there. The whole thing.
That's, that's how I'm handling
every fucking situation like that.
I'm literally putting my hands
up like a cop has a gun on me.
Um,
the fuck away from me until they bring
back due process and burden of proof.
That's I'm telling you as a man,
that is the fucking way to go,
to stick your hands up in the air until
these fucking lunatics calm the fuck
down. And they realize that our judicial
system is the best that the world has to
offer and to not do away with.
The best fucking thing about it is the
fact that you actually get a fucking,
you know the chance to defend
yourself. You know, even the guilty,
get a chance to defend themselves so
that the innocent won't go to jail. They,
you go stamps.com everybody stamps.com
brings all the amazing services of the u
s postal service right to your computer.
stamps.com not only saves you time,
it saves you money too.
With stamps.com you get discounted postage
rates that can get even that you can
get even what? That you can't
even get at the post office. Fuck.
Not to mention it's a fraction of the
cost of those expensive postage meters and
there's no equipment to least
and no long term commitments.
I use stamps.com to send out all
my posters, uh, for the store.
I'm a fucking moron. I can
figure it out. So can you, um,
although I'm not bringing in these
posters to Europe by the way,
cause I'm just going from
city to city to city to city.
I don't know how to
fucking do it over there.
I also don't know how to convert the
fucking American money to euro's,
to Frank's the fucking, uh, the blooms.
Whatever the fuck you
guys are using over there.
So I'm just gonna just gonna dance
and do my stupid fucking show, right?
stamps.com it only saves you time.
It saves you money too.
With stamps.com be kink.
You get discounted postage rates that
you can't even get at the post office.
Not to mention it's a fraction of the
cost of those expensive postage meters and
there's no equipment to lease
and no long term commitments.
MMM.
I use stamps, go, I re read this
shit. And right now you can,
you too can enjoy the stamps.com servers
with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale.
So start the new year off, right.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbirdthatstamps.com
enter
Burra
oh and
lastly, but not leastly my bookie. I know.
Fuck your up. Put a little money in the
game. You fucking So-and-so. Alright,
bowl season is he? It is Debbie. Get in
on the, actually with my booking.com.
Don't be that guy.
Don't be that fucking guy over
there with no rooting interests.
As your relatives or friends sit around
watching the game. Not this year,
uh, when they are, when there are
record 41 bowl games to bed on,
including the national
championship on January 7th.
Okay.
It really is the most,
it really is the most
wonderful time of the year.
Make sure you're already ready for the
daily action by signing up in my bookie
today. Uh, they pay, they
pay fast. When you win,
ownership really cares about good
customer service and the offer.
The craziest props, uh, when you bet,
when you bet is just as important with
who you're betting with betting on. Sorry.
And if you want to make money during the
ball season, you got to go to my bookie.
Evidently I trust them according
to the fucking copy here,
but you don't have to take my word for it.
Check them out yourself.
Join now in my bookie,
uh, join now in my Boogie,
we'll offer you a 50% deposit bonus to
make sure you have a nice bank roll for
the season. Use Promo Code Bar. I'm
assuming when you deposit to activate,
the offer just says x, x, x, uh,
that's Promo code or ed, my bookie,
you play, you win, you get paid,
they'll get the fuck Audi. Um,
all right. That's the reason for this
week. Oh, you know what I did yesterday?
I had a buddy of mine, he's a,
he's a member at a country club.
Okay.
Now this is some shit that I would
never do. I would never think to do.
I would never think to join
a country club. I don't golf.
Um, although I watched
this thing on tiger woods,
mmm.
Tiger Woods last night with
some sort of fucking 30 for 30.
Okay.
Basically on his return to
finally winning, you know,
his body was all broken down on all that
shit and they came back and he won and
other ratings went like
through the roof and all that.
It was just fucking awesome
that she was back. And you know,
when people love to watch greatness,
if you love to watch greatness,
that reflects more on you rather than
the person that you fucking watching.
Cause you just fucking pissed
off about your own life.
Why wouldn't you want to see somebody
go out and be the greatest of all time?
And anyways,
um,
so I went over there to
smoke a cigar and um,
okay.
And I went over there. It
was, it was a fucking utopia.
Like I would literally join a
country club and never play golf.
Yeah.
I went over there. They had all the
NFL Games on, they had all this food,
they were pouring booze the way I pour
booze at home, I call it like a home poor.
They were pouring in like that.
Fortunately I wasn't drinking because
I drove over there and that would have
been a situation. It would have to look
left my fucking car there. But, um,
everybody just hanging out break
and fucking balls. It was great.
And I gotta be honest with you.
It was nice,
okay.
As a guy to know that that still existed.
It was just fun.
You know,
that's like one of those things that like
feminists go after and it's just like
we're not doing anything wrong.
And then I hung out over there for like
three hours hanging out with all the
guys, everybody breaking balls,
telling stories, watching the game,
trying to fucking coach what was on the
TV, smoking cigars, classic Guy Shit.
And then I was done. And then I came
home to my wife and I was psyched.
And then it was around this female
energy. It was perfect. It was like,
dare I say balanced and um,
okay.
Do you know how this is this whole
fucking weird thing going on right now,
that if everybody is not included,
meaning both sexes,
that for some reason that means that
there's something wrong about it.
You know, I don't know. I don't
fucking get it. Like, you know,
a bunch of women going out
to Brunch is great for them.
They get to be around that. They
totally vibe with that fucking energy.
Then after a while, I imagine they,
you know, go onto my fucking dumb guy.
I'm with absence, makes the
heart grow fonder, you know,
and I understand to a certain level
where there was just like, you know,
entities and business and schmoozing
and all that that weren't letting,
you know, forget about women but other
races of people and all that, you know,
I'm, I'm, you know,
obviously not down with that.
I think everybody ought to be able to
go wherever the fuck they want to go as
long as you're not a fucking jerk off,
but I don't,
but I draw the line at that thing where
it's just everything has to have men and
women mixed together. I think, uh,
that a lot of shit should, but
I, there's definitely they do it.
They should just be some shit that's
just for women. Oh, just for men.
And even then just for men, you know,
when you call you here, I, even,
the way I worded that,
I made sure they said just for women
first before these fucking lunatics with,
I don't know what the f I've been doing
this bit right now, talking about, um,
how these private schools work.
Okay.
Now where you have to like audition your
kids over there and they're trying to
like get this perfect
balance racially and, and,
and gender and all of that.
And it's just like, it's,
it's like their heart
is in the right place,
but it just feels like this giant fucking
okay.
Like experiment, like some weird like
Nazi shit. Like what are you doing?
What the fuck are we,
the kids just let them be kids and they,
this is all gonna work out
itself. They're trying to, like,
they're trying to curate the,
the painless childhood.
I think that that's
what they're going for.
They're going to try to like
have kids have, you know,
a childhood without any pain.
Um,
which I guess then the theory is, is that
then they would go out into the world.
Okay.
And they wouldn't inflict any pain on
anybody, but it's just like eventually,
you know,
okay,
you got to go out in the real
world and this is going to be pain.
There's going to be
disappointment, there's gonna
be people stealing your shit,
and you're going to have to
know how to deal with that.
And that's kind of like what school is.
You learn how to stand up
to bullies and all that.
I'm not saying the kid should go to
school and have a miserable fucking
experiences, but like there is like
a certain element of it that you got,
you gotta let him fucking
handle it themselves.
Right.
The only way that you could possibly,
okay.
I don't know how it would work.
You would have to get rid of all the
sociopaths in all the selfish fucking
people in the world first.
He would literally have to,
and you'd have to kill them.
This whole fucking thing that you're
going to stick them on a fucking island.
He ended,
all they're gonna do is just fuck each
other and make like fucking roided up
sociopath's selfish people.
And then eventually one of them is going
to not to make a boat and then that's
going to be yet,
then they're going to come over and
we're all going to be over here like,
you know, puts you right
in, take your right hand up,
fucking singing the Hokey pokey and
weren't going to get steamrolled.
You like how I put myself not on the
island. You like, I want that story.
I was the fucking hero and I wasn't,
I wasn't a selfish cunt.
Like I wouldn't be over
there. Um, I dunno.
It is, it is weird. But, uh, I already
know what I'm going to do. I'm going to,
I'm going to, uh, get my daughter
enrolled in some sort of like a,
you know, anti bully,
Jujitsu fucking Shit,
just so my daughter knows how to
handle herself and then that's it.
And then just make sure you don't
abuse the skill set that you now have.
And if anybody comes out, yeah.
You know, you fucking handle it.
It gives you confidence and then you
don't have to spend your whole fucking
childhood in this depressive fog of
dreading going to school and shit.
You know,
and I think back as some of the periods
I went through and some of this shit,
some other kids that I picked on went
through, I'd fucking, it was like, Oh man,
that's,
that's why I'm surprised too that like
teachers intervene a little bit more,
not to the point that they're doing it
now to the point that they're doing it
now, where they're just fucking like
a, it's almost like reverse Hitler
where everyone is included,
but they're also deciding like,
who is the number one draft
pick? There's still, you know,
boxing out other people. It's weird.
It's just a really fucking weird,
I dunno, it's just such a weird God
damn time. All right. That's, that's it.
When my little fucking
pontificating there. Let's, uh,
let's do a little bit of the, uh, some
of the reeds here for the week. Um,
all right. What do we got here?
Who as far as twos first? Um,
yeah.
All right. Good Times. Bad Times. How
I learned. Hey Billy Bass drum balls.
I learned good times,
bad times when I was 12 or 13.
You mother fucker.
Thanks to my drum teacher.
No, that's awesome man. He taught me,
he'll doubt he taught
me heel down technique.
It showed me that the trick to getting
those fast flutter kicks was to move your
foot halfway down the pedal. Your heel
should be completely off the pedal.
Oh yeah. I've seen that. You
just slide up and down. Uh,
this counteracts the spring tension and
helps you play faster at the expense of
power. Oh, at the expense
of power. All right.
Eventually by doing this enough,
you will be able to play those
flutters without this. Uh,
okay.
Without this trek. Uh, it's like
training wheels. If you play heal up,
you should be able to make the swivel
technique work. It's a valuable trick.
I have tab up your sleeve
and you don't lose any punch.
I've included a link on how to
do it if you aren't too sure.
I also recommend playing cashmere is a
warmup before jumping into good times,
bad times. He does some slower flutter
kicks that will loosen you up. I hope.
Uh,
okay.
I hope I could help you on happy
new year and go fuck yourself. Um,
what I learned finally because
I was doing it the wrong way,
the first way I did it before I took
any drum lessons. When I would do it,
I would do this weird thing, what
I would curl my toe down. Yeah.
Push. And then almost like I
was almost doing that slide,
move with like my toes and I got
plantar Fisher, I to my foot.
My technique was so bad that
my drum teacher was teaching
me his technique and I
didn't understand it. And then I didn't
go in for a while and I learned it.
I was almost doing like a reverse slide.
Like I was,
I was bringing my foot back
and that was the slide.
And then pushing forward down.
Um,
okay.
So the first one was like,
light was almost like an unaccented
beat. So it was like, Duh, Duh,
Duh, Duh, Duh, Duh. And then another time
I was doing it, the first one was louder.
It was like Duh, Duh, Duh, Duh, Duh, Duh.
And it never sounded even so
the way he just taught me,
which is it was,
has been a total game changer in like
the last fucking three days I've been
messing with this shit
is all right, I play a
DW drum pedal. All right?
So when you just play in a
single, the Bali of, first of all,
you sit back and he should be able
to see your ankles a little bit.
I was sitting too close,
so my,
my knee was directly above my foot
and that was fucking with, you know,
my technique and they was in the
own past up to a certain tempo.
It was getting in the way.
So we had me move back,
which felt really fucking weird
at first and now it feels great.
So basically if you were playing a
single, you felt you're just, you know,
lift your leg up and boom, come right down
on the DW. But when you play, hang on,
oh fuck. Hang on. She's coming
in the island. All right.
The lovely knee is here. Let me, I've
got to finish, explain something here.
How are you, you know, your shirt oddly
matches the, uh, the windscreen there.
Yeah. Um, so anyways, the windscreen
that I use when I'm inside, so anyway,
it's self, you're playing a single,
you just lift your foot up and hot air,
you're blowing and that's right.
You bring it right down on the DW,
but then if you're going to play a double,
all you do is you slide your foot back
where you are right below the nine,
I played the 9,000. So if you play the
5,000 right below the five and then you,
you just bring your foot down
like you're playing a single.
So that first one is
strong. Okay. Like a single.
And then as,
as you know,
and you let the beat or come off the head
and you catch the rebound as you slide
it up and then they're both
strong in both even. Um,
and sound powerful.
Yeah,
it was just a completely different thing.
And what I ended up doing at
a slow tempo was just play.
Um, like in my time a dime, not
playing 16th on the high hat,
I was just playing dumb
boom Bopa debt, but bump up on
debt, gone to the tech boom,
boom, bump the tempo,
something like that, whatever.
So it makes sense to drummers.
Okay,
sends to drama.
So what's is key and that it was what I
being played like the immigrant song is
if you're playing singles and doubles,
you get that muscle memory
that if you play in a single,
you just keep your foot up at the top of
the pedal and then when you played the
double you B,
you're bringing it back.
And what happens is your muscle
memory is as you're playing,
whatever the fuck you playing right
before that first note of the double,
your foot's already moving back into
position and be the same thing if you're
playing a double pedal where after what?
Like when you first go from
a single to a double pedal,
that the fucking brain power that you
have to use to move your left foot from
the high hat over to the slave pedal if
you play a double pedal is like fucking
ridiculous.
But then after awhile you just,
your foot just knows to
just sort of just slide,
just to come over that, you
know, literally four inches.
But when you first start out, it's kind
of the same. Things like that. All right,
I'm done.
Sorry
Nia,
you literally just fucking glazed over.
Like probably 80% of the
people sit upon boom,
boom gap. Now. Those were all single
bull tap, boom, a wound,
whatever. It's soundproof.
It's something that I do.
It's something you should have. Good.
They sound it. You can't hear it.
Can you hear it? No, I can't hear it
from the house now. Yeah. Perfect.
That's fucking perfect. So how are you,
how was your Christmas? It was lovely.
How's your Christmas? It was
wonderful. How was your New Year?
You're doing Christmas?
Yes we did.
Or Cutie Pie still doesn't
get the whole concept.
She was more into like
opening the presence.
She liked the opening and the
ripping of the wrapping paper.
But after that she was like
done. Yes she was. She was like,
no point has no present, no present.
So that was that. So when I also love,
what does she call the Christmas tree?
Mcmurtry momentary like Christmas tree.
She was like, Mama, Mama,
she's so manipulative already and now
she knows how to get you, you know,
cause she knows how desperate we are for
her affection and her hugs and kisses.
So she just uses that. They know that
already, don't they? Yeah, absolutely.
So it's like,
you know,
she'll ask for something that she knows
she's not supposed to have and I'm like,
no, you can't have that. The Sonata.
And she'll wear me down. I'll be like,
all right, you can have a little,
she almost, you go mama, please Mama.
Or She sees that I'm about to do it.
I've given it.
And she rushes over and gives me
a kiss and a hug. So I was like,
she just knows she knows what to do.
So what's happening over here?
On the old a podcast, they attract
suit. Um, oh, I'm loving this tracksuit,
tracksuit, tracksuit, got bill all the,
a couple of tracks suits for Christmas
because it's just like what he likes to
live in slash travel in.
So you really never do what,
what's verse he's been
telling me to do forever.
And I never had always had like track
pants on and stuff at the airport and like
a zip up. No, cause you know
what happens is because I,
I forget my wallet or phone,
most of them don't have back pockets.
That was that time I went to the airport
and I missed my flight because I had my
phone in my front pocket and I wasn't
even thinking I didn't have my wallet and
I didn't have my license.
And then I had a flight fucking private
that costs me a zillion dollars. That's,
it was an afternoon gig. Yeah. So I get
super paranoid and then I don't like,
I don't like sweatpants when I fly because
shit just slides out of your pockets
and then your wallet goes underneath
the seats if somebody has to find the
fucking thing. So, um,
but other than that,
they're great to fly in. So
I just, you know something,
I put it in the the hopefully, yes.
See these don't have zipper pockets.
Yes.
So this is a very vulnerable,
this is like the thing that the Gypsies
over there and you're not supposed to
say Gypsies by the way. I don't
know what, see if that's no offense.
I don't think so.
I think you're,
you're not supposed to say I got gypped
anymore cause I think that's offensive.
Um, Gypsies, Gypsies,
but I actually like you're not
supposed to call them. I don't know.
Isn't there a TV show called like
Gypsy nation or something? I Dunno.
I think Gypsy's is fine.
But maybe you associate them with like
pick pocketing and being scammers or you
mean like what happened to us
when we were over there is rude
and you're not supposed to say that.
You're not supposed to say what the
fuck is happening. No. All right,
well then fine.
I don't need to get involved in this
cause I'm going to fucking eastern Europe
of right, exactly. Probably
lay off the old gray,
the harmful history of gypsy.
This is on bitch media.
So I don't think that this is going to be
what is with all these fucking people
asking for money. All right. Uh,
as a Romanian woman,
right,
more often called by the racial slur
gypsy, I didn't know that was a,
that's a racial slur. Yeah. I, I feel
like I learned that a couple of years ago,
but I'm,
but I watch TV networks,
original Siri Gypsy with some trepidation.
The show is a psychological
thriller for the most part,
without many thrills, but blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
He watched show that I watched two
episodes and then for the show takes its
inspiration from Stevie Nicks Song Gypsy
about a free spirited woman who loves
and disappears.
So to me that's what a gypsy was.
A Gypsy was just the nomadic person.
Like I didn't know any of this shit
about pickpocket and all that shit.
The mythos. So he said, oh,
the gyms is of the Gypsy is a
steward stereotype. The thief,
the Fortune Teller, the free
spirit, the seductress and the liar.
And Jean hits all of them,
rebranding them as characteristics
of a wealthy white woman.
Just trying to find herself. That's
kind of true. Wait, what's that song?
Gypsy was, man, what's that? What's
that song that's from the said no,
it's witchy woman.
Oh,
you're so racist against gypsy.
You're throwing that word in. Wow.
I'm not, no, I, you know, I tried
to be sensitive to stuff like that.
Oh,
what is it now? It's witchy
woman. Ooh. Where'd you
Ooh,
it's not gypsy.
We'll see how
you obviously know the lyrics more than
I do. Well I think just for, you know,
just don't call anybody a
gypsy. Alright, I'll try it.
If I have a Stevie nicks song,
the Romanian people are an oppressed
ethnic minority who's disparate roots date
back to the 10th century,
India and are currently in the midst
of century long human rights crisis.
See now it's interesting to me cause they
have their own country because
of Romania. Right? Don't they?
Isn't that their own country?
I feel like everything that I'm saying
is fucking offending somebody here.
Probably who,
who are who
passing them? Um, I don't know. I mean,
I know Russia controlled a lot of that
part. Can we blame them? The Russians,
can we blame them? They're like, you
can blame the Russians and it's okay.
I don't know.
Probably not long
when rights crisis,
one part is one that is
in part perpetuated by the
stereotypes of the Gypsies
yet almost no one but the,
but the Roman themselves are pushing
back on the series title slur,
the writing to the network and producers
are creating petition to change the
show's title along with simple ignorance.
Anti Romanian sentiment is so normalized
that in 2017 a premiere streaming
service can release a show that takes an
actual racial slur and its title and no
one bats an eyelash. Well, in
defense of Netflix over here,
Gypsy sort of a cool,
hey man,
like I'm not stuck in the matrix
kind of thing like over here.
It doesn't mean that
like I never thought like Gypsy
yet was definitely fortune teller.
It was us and then I then think of
like a just a frisk, bearded hippy.
I would like growing up,
you hear like a gypsy person that
someone who is, you know, yeah.
Doing like scams and stuff.
So you heard that I didn't
even know I associated it with,
and then we'll either go to
Europe and people were like,
be careful of the Gypsies,
a Rabi let you know what I mean.
And then I didn't know that Gypsies
were an af actual ethnicity. Right.
I just thought it was like a hippie.
Anybody can be a fucking hippie man.
And you get a tambourine and grow your
fucking hair and smoke a little grass and
all of a sudden the hippie and all this.
Yeah.
All of a sudden you're in the drum
drum culture. Right? That's not it.
That's not inferior in a drum
circle and hippie. But I'm
no bro. No, no, no, no, no,
no, no. But I'm saying, I thought
Gypsy was like that. Well, I could,
I could become a hippie if I've got some
hair transplants and started smoking
some weed man. And just did
you know, wearing Birkenstocks.
I could be considered a hippie. I didn't
know that it was an ethnicity. Right.
So we're learning something here.
Wait,
would you ever get one of those
scalp Taiwan? Let you do it.
One of those scalps what did they call it?
Scalp transplants.
Like the Tattoo Scalp. Oh yeah, no, it's,
that's different than a scalp
transplant off a murderer.
And then I have even more of a temper.
I can help transplant scouts or has flat,
uh, yeah, I forgot what
it's called. Anyway, someone
else people don't follow on.
Instagram does it for people.
Like it's a new thing that he started to
do and he calls it like the scalp shop
or something. And so I was
watching a video of the process.
It's not a new thing that's been
around for a while. Oh, it has.
I know it's a Tatsu. Yeah, I knew a guy
that did it is a, it's permanent then.
No, it actually fades. You supposed
to keep your head out of the light.
But what it looks like, it ends up
looking like I have a full head of hair,
but just tried to shape
a, decided to shave it down. It's not
like a five o'clock shadow on your head.
Yeah. But then what? This
is what's weird to me.
It's like now I got to shake
my head every fucking day.
A variety because that is going to
be weird because then the stumbled,
the real hair is going to be coming
up and then the rest of the shit,
I think you can go like a day or two
before it starts looking stupid. Yeah,
I know. I am not a, I am not a big
believer in fucking with nature.
Okay. So if, if nature has matrix
then letting you know,
play the hand that you're dealt and
you, you play it to the best. Right.
So I keep myself in shape. I grew the
beard, I just shaved it off and you know,
this is who I am talking about
shaving your beard off the other day.
And I was just like, why would you ever
do that? Because I miss my face. Oh Jesus.
Nia, you may be familiar,
familiar with the word Jip,
which means to cheat someone
right as a gypsy would.
It's a slur as obviously
offensive as Jew down.
And yet people still say it.
Say what you down,
you never heard that you grew
up in Massachusetts for awhile?
I mean I lived there until I was like sex.
I grew up in Atlanta once you would think.
Yeah,
yeah,
I know there,
there are Jewish people,
they got tails like they went to a whole
other level down there and yet people
still say in everyday
and everyday combination.
Imagine replacing Gypsy Gypsy as the
show title with another ethnic slur.
The show would never have been made and
yet gypsy was made riding on the back of
their romantic popularization of the
world of fashion, beauty and social media.
Yet that's how I view it.
No. So I guess I will stop
saying gypsy. Yeah. And sobs.
I will say Romanian
we speak. Speaking of tails,
cause you mentioned tales earlier.
Did you see that video on Twitter?
Ooh,
Romanian woman?
No.
Did you see that video on Twitter
of the raccoon? This is in Florida.
Raccoon. You know Mike, one of my least
favorite animals, like attacking a lizard,
like one of those big
fucking lizards and like,
like chasing it through a
parking lot. Oh my God, man.
The heebie jeebies just thinking about it,
chasing it through a parking lot and
just like thinking it's like tea than to
its neck and just holding it down and
then like dragging it out of frame and
then the person pans over to what looks
like a snake flapping around and you're
just like, what the fuck is going
on? Then you realize it's the tail.
It's the Lizard's tale that has somehow
gotten like away from the lizards body
and it's still flapping around on its own.
It's the most spots of video.
Everett's and I love nature video
watching. I fucking hate falls.
It's so, I don't hate
reptiles. Ooh, regret
rub. Can you imagine calling
your show reptiles a yes.
Did I come in here to answer
a question or no? No, no.
I to see a raccoon
verse Lizard. Yeah. Florida.
Cause you know all that shit
always happens. Oh yeah.
Florida is fucking crazy.
Raccoon kills a Guana and Guana.
Oh Man,
I like Iguanas AG.
You're bound to get your heartbroken.
Oh No. Oh yes. Oh I like, Rudolph was
so brutal,
Dude.
What the fuck does Gordon Ramsay have
to do with the goddamn lizard eat. Oh,
I see. He's fixing these people's
restaurant. That's hilarious.
Do my favorite part about him going to
his restaurants is when Gordon Ramsay
starts gagging. Right. There's always
something in the fucking freezer.
No, it smells that bed when
they have meat from like, yeah,
2002 when there, yeah. Oh my
God. He one time, like he,
I thought he was just acting and then
the camera man almost puked. I was like,
Oh wow, that's real.
[inaudible]. Here we go. Oh No.
Oh No.
He's going,
oh,
should I stop the fight?
No.
Yeah, he's dead. Let him go dog.
Where the fuck did that?
God Damn
Holy.
It's on a basis,
please.
Sure.
Oh Jesus Christ. Let me ask
you this question. Who Does?
Nobody has an Iguana in flips a pet,
so we just let that thing go.
Hmm. Well, you just saw was how
long I would last in prison.
You know?
I was really like that guy was saying
that fucking lizard did not have a goddamn
chance. Yeah. It's not
natural to fucking Florida.
Somebody got sick of feed
nick grasshoppers and it,
it is let it go and then it got eaten by
a fuck. You might not lizard been like,
what in the fuck is this thick?
You would survive in prison based
on your windows and your yeah.
Well no because you like have so much
anger inside of you that you would be able
to channel it and you'd be able
to like the funny like killer guy.
He'll make you laugh but all
he'll make you cry. No, sorry.
I was thinking I've learned
from anybody in prison.
It's just like some of the
toughest fucking guys I
haven't met. They were like,
do not go in there acting like you're the
toughest fucking guy cause you're not.
Who has conversations like this?
Like why do you even think about like
how you would do in prison? Like are you,
is there something that
you need to tell me? No,
it's just she just watched those things.
They made some fucking option. Yeah.
Can happen.
I never think about that and everything
about how would I do in prison.
Even your privileged
world. Oh here we go. Wait.
But I want to say something about the,
um, we'll try to say, oh wait, wait, wait.
So that guy on the video was saying,
oh, should I break up the fight?
Should I stop it? And I said, no,
I don't understand why people where
people feel like they need to get like
involved in nature and nature. I was
reading this article, I saw that.
What do you mean?
Because whoever,
I probably fucking bought that Lizard
to Florida was a white person on some
levels. Guessing. Well, I'm just saying
like sometimes you just have to let,
I left this comment on New York,
the New York magazine Instagram page,
because they had a whole article about
how seals are snorting eels, seals,
sea lions are snorting eels as like this.
They're like,
they're young and they snore them.
It's like for fun or something like that.
And someone left a comment like, oh,
I hope whoever took that picture,
like put the camera down
and like intervenes and like
help that poor sea lion.
And I was like, sometimes you've just got
to let nature nature wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. This snorting,
they're snorting yields. Wait,
you have to Google as sea
lions are snorting eels,
like following like a line of coke.
Yes.
And there's a picture of a snail with
like a sea lion or the very satisfied look
on his face with an eel up its nose.
That's just what they're doing now.
I don't know why, but
someone was like, oh,
somebody should intervene and pull it out
and just let nature do what it's gonna
do. Planking or like throwing the
water bottle and having it land. Yeah,
they were little Instagram. Yeah, that's
exactly what scientists were saying.
They like,
it's a new thing that they just apparently
are just doing for fun because they
can do so it's like just let them smart.
Like you don't have to get involved to
like seal. Like why? What does, I dunno.
I don't understand that impulse to
intervene when nature is nature occurring,
people are control freaks.
It's one thing if you see iot
attacking your cat or dog of course.
But I mean if it's,
if it has sea lion and the eel or an
Iguana and a flush of what you're saying,
you're saying that a dog and a cat is
more of an animal worth saving than a
lizard or an eel. One of them
is that his animals, racism,
animal phobic. Speciesism you're wild
a phobic. You don't like wild animals.
No, I'm saying if they're in the wild
and they're doing their thing, just let,
let them do what they're going to do.
Why do you need to get involved and like,
oh, how do you decide whose side to
beyond just because the iguanas losing,
all of a sudden you're anti the
raccoon like you know, go lighter skin.
You pick the lighter skin analog.
Okay.
Repairing electronics. All right,
so I'm not saying Gypsy anymore.
My apologies to a Romanian people.
Yeah, you don't have that screwed,
but then that's saying
offensive prostitutes.
I'm going to say like boxes or something.
No carpenters.
All right on on. He screwed
me. Hey, I've been a carpenter
on repairing electronics.
Hello Bill.
You mentioned in a previous podcast
that you like getting your electronics
repaired and even knew
a guy that did that.
It's amazing with a quick youtube video,
people can repair their own products.
Well guess what apple
like always is that one company that
likes to shit all over that they seize
shipments with quality third parties,
party parts from these repair shops
because they want you to pay the 800 plus
she would otherwise be saving.
Wow.
Trusted repair shops get
third party parts illegal.
But apple likes legally sorry,
but apple likes to have customers hold
them from these guys and make them pay
obnoxious fees to receive the packages.
When you have the time,
take a look at this short video. You know,
we should ask the pys. It goes too far.
Are Our electronics are parents
like our computers and stuff?
We should ask them about that.
You know what?
We found a repairman who uh,
just fixed our stove and it's fucking
amazing. He, what did you say?
He made that stuff is bad. He did. He
took the whole thing apart. So now we had,
we had,
we have a 10 year old Viking stove that
is now 2018 it's basically a resto mod.
If you were into cars,
which is if you had an 1965 whatever,
and on top it looks like 1965 oh wait,
so it doesn't do,
it doesn't do that anymore when
I wish you wouldn't either.
I don't have time to watch this,
but I'm definitely going to watch this.
It's called a,
the name of this video is apple under
fire for allegation of controversial
business practices. Did you
get this for the baby? Oh wait,
is this yours? Oh yeah, I was going
to give that the Bert Kreischer,
I forgot that is a Florida state half
shirt that I bought in 1981 or 82 and
never wore it.
I crop top.
I never wore vintage Florida
state crop top half shirt.
Crop top. No, they'll call
the half shirts back then.
You're going to give it to
time for Chrysler? Yeah. Wow.
Can he fit like an arm in
here? No, I didn't realize
it's a small, you know what?
Yeah, I'd like to see you
wear that now. So not an owl.
You know what shape it is,
what it is.
I think you were also,
you mentioned your DVD or Blu Ray player
didn't have HD m I for your new TV you
can buy in RCA to HTM.
I converted for a couple of bucks to plug
in an old video equipment or our GB to
HD.
M I depending on what you have,
RCA is the red is the cable with red,
white and yellow.
RGB is the cable with red,
green and blue as this is a real
fucking nerdy ass podcast today, Huh?
No, this asshole.
Ooh, bitchy will bay. Watch it.
Watch it all. We got time to
read two more here. Home Sauna.
Merry Christmas, Billy. Big Balls.
Merry Christmas to you and yours and
I hope you're having a lovely restful
festive break. I just wanted to
weigh in on your home saunas.
Som Sana comments. I couldn't remember.
I couldn't recommend getting one more.
I live in west Wales and
built a sauna three years ago.
It's the perfect way to level your body
and mind three times a week is perfect,
but I generally do to,
the best way I found is 15 minutes in
the sauna to a cold shower out cold
outdoor shower, three repeat steps
one and two, three times and all.
Uh,
the level of chill I have afterwards can
only otherwise be obtained by illegal
means.
It's awesome.
I'm telling you any of this is going to
help us if I get something like this.
Looking forward to seeing
you in Manchester. I fucking
love Manchester. Okay. Yeah,
they are like, I went to,
I went there. I was like,
these guys are like the same kind of
fucking lunatics I remember in Boston.
Same thing, Paul breaking,
drinking, fucking I love it. Uh,
and I'm thinking Liverpool's going to
be the same way in all like all up to
there. I'm not doing a
new castle, I don't think,
but I just feel like all up there is that
type of shit where London is more like
Manhattan, where it's all
refined oils, real phones. Uh,
thanks for bringing up my
workweek and look after yourself.
I would love to figure out a way to do
this. I just don't have the room here.
What's wrong with the steam though?
That's different from, well,
a sauna you can go way harder
because with steam it's, it's,
it's so wet.
Like I mean is steam.
You can actually sit in a sauna it like
close to 200 degrees and if you were in
a sauna where it was just all, all
on Asana, fucking steam. Yeah. Yeah.
You literally be getting to the point
where the water on you was getting close
to starting to boil. You
know, he could burn yourself.
I never understood. This is,
and this is also me speaking,
just trying to remember repeating
what people were talking about Saunas,
but I am sold on them. Um, to the point.
There's one I know that,
you know, maybe we could go,
maybe we can go take a sauna
today if you want it to.
And they have like the Finnish one,
not like finish. I'm done like Finland.
And then also they're known for that shit.
Yeah.
Although recently just had a competition.
So many fucking died over there.
I'm like sitting in like hot they hot box.
You can't say I didn't try.
I would try but I don't know.
I said has never been my thing to just
like sit in like wow, I'm very hot.
My things just sit in the hot.
The old hot box. I like to hotbox
to sit in the hot bar. Right.
I gotta wrap this up cause I got a
phone call in a minute. All right.
Threesome with my ex girlfriend a deal.
Dear Billy Barron's skull birth.
Oh,
I recently been going through some of
your Cadillac podcasts and highlights and
become a huge fan of always have your
podcast playing at any opportunity I get.
But without further ado, here's
my dilemma. He 16 in high school,
recently started dating
this girl at school.
We've been going steady
and pardon my graphing.
This had been doing it like rabbits.
Now these are like underage people.
My allowed to read this. Feel like
this is the point where you stop, stop.
This is where I stopped.
Right. Okay. All right.
I'm going to stop with
underage threesomes.
Um,
is it the cops?
I'm not cool. Yeah, mania and I go there.
Why don't you a hype your Instagram page?
Hey everybody, follow
me on Ige. Sorry. Wait,
you're looking at me and slowly lap a,
everybody knows my Instagram.
It's a Nias alter ego.
Everybody talk.
He is that he is all three of
ego. Alter Egos. The same one.
Twitter as it is on
Instagram. Ma. Um, yeah,
there you go. Follow me. There you go.
Cause you build your brand
as I build my brand. Uh,
can we come to England when you do that,
when we go to build your brand in
England? No. Can we, me and the baby come.
It's your England runned. Oh yeah, sure.
You kind of put me on the spot here.
Yeah. Know. Asking me on the market. Okay.
Evidently this trip is going to cost.
Uh, well I figured you do your short,
you can stay a little bit longer and you
know, I dunno. You know, I love London.
I love London. Don't make me
laugh and made me laugh alone.
Face
to me,
that's our favorite movie of all
time. I'm sweating here, a roasting,
baking, boiling, boop,
boop, boop, boop, boop.
And it's like a sauna. Zuora. Oh,
it's came full circle. That's
me and bbs. Favorite movie.
Kalimari what you have, what you
have in, what were you having?
And we ran into them that time
when we met down tree. Yes.
Roundtree yes you will. You will. You will
find fuck off. You're doing it.
I hope this plane crashes.
That's my favorite line.
The Egd movies. So cool.
I love when he talks about
it. I get molested. He
touched me on the plane. Yeah,
I was scared. I didn't know what to do.
I've been, I've been touched up and touch.
He totally fucking gets out of
it. Um, Kelsey, a sexy beast.
If you haven't not go see it,
I guess rented or,
I don't know how you
procure old movies nowadays,
but I'm sure it's on one of these
streaming services. Streaming services.
Streaming services.
If it's not on Netflix,
we need to have a conversation
with Ted Sarandos about that.
Ted Sarandos sexy beast on Netflix.
And that was,
what is it? The good guys? What's that?
Ryan Gosling movie that I fucking love it.
I have a sense of that. I fucking loved
it. I still haven't seen that movie,
Ryan Gosling and, um, um, um, Russell,
Russell Crowe also cross will always be
my favorite because he threw that phone
at the fucking guy,
wouldn't help him with the phone.
And I always thought how satisfying that
would be when someone is not helping
you with something and you throw
thing that literally the thing,
they're not helping you with.
You throw it at them. Sure.
There's regret afterwards in
the mall in the moment. Again,
it felt so good.
The release.
That's an angry sauna. All right. I gotta
go. Happy New Year everybody. Thank you.
Thank you.
Once again,
my apologies to the people in the or
last night I fucked up had I know. Uh,
that's all on me.
That's not on the comedy store.
So send all your complaints to me. Um,
all right, that's it. Go fuck yourselves.
And I'll check in on you hopefully on
Thursday. I think I'll still be traveling.
I'll be ahead of the game. I'll be ahead
of the game. See you in 2019. Oh, Jesus.
All right. Bye. Bye.